I'm sorry that I didn't consider you as
I didn't I was I was so caught up and
they I don't want to cry I was just
caught up in that pain
yeah right yeah and also that pain of
others yeah and the effects that it had
Jada pinkett-smith and Leah Remini
coming a face to face on it Jada's at
Facebook watch series at read table talk
Leah reached out to me and she opened a
space for healing between us I embraced
it and so we decided to bring it to the
table the sit-down is years in the
making the actress has fell out when
leah publicly accused Jada of being a
Scientologist after an appearance on
Bravo's watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen on which Jada made a light of
Leah's claims in her 2015 book a
troublemaker about participating in a
game of adult hide-and-go-seek at Tom
Cruise's house have you played this is
when our kids were really small okay Tom
love games that was the whole point of
tom was just fun like that so I know she
kind of made it seem kind of weird right
but it really wasn't it was just a bunch
of us goofing off with our kids and
Gatlin silly games fair game is a policy
in Scientology that calls for the utter
destruction of a critic of Scientology
daddy you get trained on how to do this
universe deal with it with a laugh you
know like it's boring and the second
thing is a discredit right the facts
that's why I said then Jada is a
Scientologist because there's no reason
for Jada to be doing that other than
fair gaming me just so you know I wasn't
fair gaming you on Andy Cohen this talk
was the first time that Jada ever
explained her involvement with the
controversial church which Leah
of course left for years it's been
rumored that I was a Scientologist
because I took some courses at the
church and was interested in study tech
one of the organizations teaching
methods I also opened a school that used
the study tech which added to the
speculation you saw me at the
Scientology Center
religion cuz I grew up in the ethical
Society yeah so my grandmother was like
you're gonna learn all the religions and
then you got to decide which one yeah
you want to practice love that so for me
yeah all religions have been my home
sure which is why I didn't have a
problem going to the Church of
Scientology and saying I'm not a
Scientologist I want to just be here and
see what you have to offer right because
I'm that was my life because of Jada's
celebrity status Leah says she got
access to Scientology texts that most
people would have to work years for and
spend lots of money to get their hands
on
but Jada made it clear she's never
officially joined the church and
supports Leah search for Shelly
Miscavige the wife of Scientology leader
David Miscavige who has not been seen
publicly in years where is your friend
where is she yeah you know and I had a
lot of respect for the fact that you
would not give up on that question well
it's still not answered today right
despite me hire a lawyer and that lawyer
through the Public Information Act
trying to get information we are still
stuck being Stonewall today about where
is Shelly Miscavige leaders wife Jada
gives all credit to Leah for reaching
out to mend their relationship admitting
she probably wouldn't have ever made
that call herself it's just never too
late you know for friends for families
you know it's just never too late to
heal
[Applause]
you